[Applaus]
[Musik]
das jahr 2023 begann fast wie eine reise
in die vergangenheit alle scheinwerfer
der weltpolitik richteten sich auf die
nachfolgestaaten der untergegangenen
sowjetunion sozusagen als neue jahres
begrüßung gab es einen massiven
aufmarsch russischer truppen an der
grenze zur ukraine und am sechsten
januar wurde in kasachstan die erste
militärmissionen der sogenannten
organisation des vertrags über
kollektive sicherheit gestattet eine art
nato unter russischer führung sie tritt
gewissermaßen das erbe des warschauer
pakts an in diesem fall geht es um die
entsendung von rund 2500 soldaten unter
dem kommando dieses mannes des
russischen generaloberst andreas
rothkopf der 2014 die militär operation
zur eroberung wird grimm leitete und
anschließend die russische streitkräfte
in syrien befehligte
zu den nach kasachstan entsandten
truppen gehörten auch soldaten der 45
einheit die für ihre einsätze in den
tschetschenien kriegen für ihre
beteiligung eine annex i und ekrem und
für ihre intervention in syrien bekannt
ist jetzt wurden die truppen nach
kasachstan ein sand um die proteste
niederzuschlagen die zu beginn des neuen
jahres in weiten teilen des landes gegen
die regierung von präsident
casting-format edf ausgebrochen waren
[Musik]
nun fragt sich aber vielleicht der ein
oder andere warum uns das alles denn
sonderlich interessieren sollte haben
wir den nicht genug eigene probleme zum
beispiel mit den explodierenden
energiepreisen ja ich liebe visual
politik zuschauer calasan ist nicht nur
eines der flächenmäßig größten länder
der welt sondern auch ein wichtiger
akteur für manche gar ein keyplayer in
der globalen energiewirtschaft neben
vielen anderen ressourcen verfügt das
land über die zwölf größten
erdölreserven der welt und fördert mehr
als 40 prozent des weltweit abgebauten
urans habe dass euer interesse geweckt
gut aber was genau ist in kasachstan
eigentlich passiert wie konnte es so
weit kommen dass russische truppen
einmarschieren mussten ist kassandra
putin eine art blaupause für weitere
interventionen wie lässt sich der
wachsende interventionismus von wladimir
putins russland erklären und was in den
möglichen folgen für auslands machbaren
wie zb die ukraine aber auch für ganz
europa all diese fragen werden wir in
diesem video beantworten haltet euch
also fest denn wir haben eine wilde
fahrt fort bevor wir loslegen habe ich
aber noch eine gute nachricht für euch
und für uns auf der suche nach einem
sponsor der nicht nur für uns sondern
auch von hohem nutzen sein kann sind wir
auf die klage abgestoßen klage ist quasi
der versicherungsmakler dem set immer
auf seinem handy dabei hat man kann mit
ihr all seine versicherungen managen und
optimieren und so natürlich geld sparen
nun mag sich der ein oder andere
vielleicht fragen ob ein
versicherungsmakler wirklich etwas
bringt man könnte seine versicherungen
ja auch selbst abschließen dazu kann ich
allein aus eigener erfahrung sagen mehr
persönlich hat eine anbieter
unabhängiger versicherungsmakler
ersparnis in höhe von tausenden von euro
gebracht als wenn ich mich selbst um den
richtigen versicherungsschutz gekümmert
hätte konkret ging es bei mir um die
private krankenversicherung einen vor
allem rechtlich sehr komplexes feld auf
welchem ich ohne die fachkompetenzen und
beratung eines maklers einen viel zu
teuren und auch suboptimalen vertrag
abgeschlossen hätte auch beim einer kfz
versicherung erfuhr ich erst viel zu
spät dass ich die gleiche
versicherungsleistung für fast 200 euro
weniger bekommen könnte denn wer hat
schon zeit und lust jedes jahr alle
seine versicherung zu checken und mit
den aktuell günstigsten angeboten am
wald zu vergleichen und das sind jetzt
nur zwei beispiele die mir direkt wieder
fahren und hat den ich gemerkt habe dass
ich ein anbieter unabhängiger
versicherungsmakler wirklich lohnen kann
ich denke dass viele gar nicht ahnen
dass ich schon die ganze zeit viel zu
viel für ihre laufenden policen bezahlen
bei clark legt man nun einfach seine
aktuellen versicherungsverträge hoch und
erteilt damit einen makler mandat diese
gegen die tarife von über 160
versicherungsunternehmen zu checken und
gegebenenfalls nach einer zustimmung zu
kündigen und woanders nun abzuschließen
natürlich stehen einem dabei die
experten von clark per telefon e-mail
oder chat zur verfügung und das ganz
ohne wartezeit das heißt ab jetzt ist
faulheit absolut kein argument mehr
dafür jährlich hunderte von euro für
überteuerte versicherungsverträge
herauszuwerfen umgekehrt wird klagte
auch einen persönlichen bedarfs checks
durch das heißt ob man nicht in
bestimmten bereichen unterversichert ist
es gibt auch eine funktion mit der man
sich seine spätere rente ausrechnen
lässt und so ganz schnell sieht ob man
eigentlich genug fürs alter vorsorgt und
dann später nicht dank versorgungslücke
ganz schön dumm und arm aus der wäsche
zu gucken wenn du dich bei klagt mit dem
kot visual 45 anmeldest bekommst du
außerdem für die ersten drei
versicherungsverträge die übermittelte
15 euro insgesamt also 45 euro als
amazon gutschein dieser gutscheincode
ist in deutschland als auch in
österreich gültig denn links vom angebot
findest du in der beschreibung unter
diesem video die dienste von clive sich
übrigens kostenlos der makler finanziert
sich wie üblich aus der provision der
versicherungsanbieter allerdings betont
klagt dass es nicht die produkte mit der
dicksten provision anbietet sondern die
mit dem besten
preis-leistungs-verhältnis und fit für
den kunden so und nun die da zum thema
unseres heutigen videos und r brennenden
frage was in kasachstan eigentlich
passiert ist was genau hinter der
intervention russische truppen in dem
zentralasiatischen land steckt und
welche folgen dies für die weltpolitik
und für europa haben kann also
aufgepasst
eine plutokratie in flammen
am ersten januar hob die kasachische
regierung die preiskontrolle für lpg
also autogas auf desjenigen kraftstoffs
der von überwiegende mehrheit der
kasachischen autofahrer genutzt wird und
so fort nachdem die preis deckelung
aufgehoben wurde schossen die
treibstoffkosten für ottonormal kasache
über nacht um sagenhafte 140 prozent
nach oben und das war der tropfen der
das fass zum überlaufen brachte
denn kasachstan ist ein land das in den
letzten drei jahrzehnten dank seiner
bodenschätze sehr viel geld verdient hat
trotzdem ist der lebensstandard
insgesamt recht niedrig dass durch die
skulls liegt bei und 500 euro pro monat
und die große mehrheit der bevölkerung
verdient noch viel weniger seit jahren
von die regierung kasachstans das land
zu einer der krassesten plutokratie in
der welt der absoluten herrschaft
erreichen
[Musik]
wovon genau wir hier reden bist du
beweise sehen nun laut kpmg
kontrollieren nur 162 einzelpersonen
mehr als 55 prozent des gesamten
vermögens im land und nein wir sprechen
hier nicht von erfolgreichen
unternehmern oder geschäftsleute die
meisten von ihnen sind verwandte freunde
oder verbündete des ehemaligen
staatschefs nursultan nasarbajew als
status der ihnen den schlüssel zu den
reichtümern des landes gab willkommen in
kasachstan
die situation spitzte sich am 2 januar
zu als in shanghai in einer kleinen
stadt in der nähe des kaspischen meeres
die die aus der zeit gefallen zu sein
scheint proteste ausbrachen von dort
breiteten sie sich bald über weite teile
des landes aus da die entrüstung über
die kraftstoffpreise in allgemein ins
horn gegenüber der regierungspolitik
umschlug zunächst verliefen die proteste
friedlich doch plötzlich gerieten die
dinge vor allem in almaty der größten
stadt des landes außer kontrolle zu dem
friedlichen demonstranten gesetzen sich
viel gewalttätige gruppen die nicht
damit zu gelten die staatlichen
sicherheitskräfte zu konfrontieren
in almaty ezb setzten sie polizeiautos
und das rathaus in brand stunden
polizeistationen und lagerhäuser
versuchten den flughafen zu übernehmen
und beschlagnahmten sogar eine menge
waffen wir sprechen von
bürgerkriegsähnlichen zuständen auf der
einen seite haben mehr als 1000
polizisten und angehörige der
sicherheitskräfte ihr leben verloren auf
der anderen seite gibt es dutzende von
opfern unter den demonstranten
wahrscheinlich geht es sogar in die
hunderte
neunter januar 2022 kasachstan 164 tote
bei protesten land jetzt stabilisiert
diese offiziellen zahlen scheinen jedoch
weit von der realität entfernt zu sein
in der regierung reagierte rücksichtslos
sie forderte die intervention
ausländischer truppen an er möchte ich
die sicherheitskräfte ohne vorwarnung zu
schießen verhängte den ausnahmezustand
eine ausgangssperre und ordnete eine
welle von hausdurchsuchungen an um
regierungskritiker ausfindig zu machen
zu verhaften und brutal zu misshandeln
das fünfstöckige polizeirevier war eine
art folter fließband die schreie konnte
man von allen fenstern aus höheren die
folterungen waren entsetzlich als
sap-chef einen teilnehmer der anti
regierungsproteste in almaty aber wie
genau ist es bis zu diesem schrecklichen
exzessen gekommen worum ging es bei den
protesten wirklich
[Musik]
nun fakt ist dass die zahl der
unbekannten sehr hoch ist und es
hypothesen für so gut wie jeden
geschmack gibt was wenn die dinge nur
deswegen außer kontrolle geraten sind
weil einige organischen die proteste aus
nutzen wollten um mehr einfluss zu
gewinnen vielleicht verbündete des
ehemaligen präsidenten nasarbajew was
wäre wenn die eskalation der proteste in
wirklichkeit eine false flag operation
der regierung war was wenn ausländische
kräfte dahinter stecken wie zum beispiel
der kreml was wäre wenn alles so das
ergebnis davon war dass die jugend ist
einfach leid war in armut und ohne
perspektive zu leben während sich eine
winzige minderheit im ganzen reichtum
des landes unter den nagel reißt oder
vielleicht eine kombination all dessen
[Musik]
was wir auf jeden fall sicher wissen ist
dass die regierung von präsident drucker
unterstützt von russland in den tagen
nach den protesten massive repressionen
und eine gigantische strafaktion
durchgezogen hat es wird geschätzt dass
die behörden mehr als 10.000 menschen
verhaftet haben diese tatsache und die
explosive situation haben klare gewinner
und verlierer hinterlassen was meinst du
wer hat den meisten profit daraus
gezogen nun der erste klare gewinner war
präsident türkei selbst und die ganze
sache ist so dass dieser präsident der
2009 10 nach dem rücktritt des
langjährigen diktators nulltarif an die
macht kam ist jetzt die macht
gewissermaßen mit ihm teilen musste denn
obwohl dabei auf offizielles rückgrat
sorgte er dafür dass er zum führer der
nation und zum chef des nationalen
sicherheitsrats ernannt wurde pokal
feiern der lage dieser schizophrenen
doppelherrschaft im land ein ende zu
setzen er wurde nie ein vollwertiger
präsident weil ihnen die hände gebunden
war doch die unruhen haben alles
verändert hat eine neue regierung
ernannt das update als chef des
nationalen sicherheitsrates entlassen
und auch viele verbündet und verwandte
des ehemaligen führers aus ihren
machtpositionen entfernt
[Musik]
dies ist zb der fall von ihrem us ihm
auf dem chef des kasachischen
geheimdienstes der rechten hand
nasarbajew maximov wurde nicht nur
gefeiert sondern anschließend gleich
verhaftet und wegen hochverrats
angeklagt ein weiteres beispiel ist
samara bisch der neffe des ehemaligen
führers der als stellvertretender
direktor des wichtigsten sicherheits
dienste des landes entlassen wurde und
nicht nur das der präsident selbst hat
den ehemaligen regierungschef im
parlament beschuldigt einen ungarischen
staat geschaffen zu haben damit sich
einige wenige auf kosten der mehrheit
bereichern können als ob er selbst damit
gar nichts zu tun hätte die unruhen sind
zu einer echten gelegenheit geworden den
kasachen zu zeigen dass das land nur
einem mann gehören kann doch es ist bis
heute die wichtigste politische figur im
land und derjenige der die wichtigsten
entscheidungen trifft eduard polizei als
kasachischer politikwissenschaftler
tatsächlich erklärt dieses szenario auch
das eingreifen der russischen
streitkräfte sie sollen alle nächtigen
in kasachstan klar machen dass tokio auf
das sagen hat und zwar genau aus dem
grund weil er die unterstützung von
wladimir putin höchstpersönlich genießt
mit anderen worten der russische einsatz
diene nicht dazu die proteste zu beenden
sondern war in erster linie eine
machtdemonstration mit der allen
endgültig klargemacht werden sollte wie
die hackordnung ist so kalt ist der
unumstrittene landesfürst zwar und
putins gnaden für tokio war es wichtig
den menschen den eliten in kasachstan zu
zeigen dass er die person ist auf die
bucht dem 6 alexander leben an professor
für russische und osteuropäische politik
an der freien universität berlin und das
bringt uns direkt zum zweiten großen
gewinner dieses sturms der sich auf den
zweiten blick trotz der vielen opfer als
sturm im wasserglas entpuppt vladimir
putin
[Musik]
bis jetzt hat kasachstan immer versucht
ein gewisses gleichgewicht in seinen
beziehungen zu russland china und den
vereinigten staaten zu waren in der tat
öffnete dass dabei das land für die
großen amerikanischen und europäischen
ölfirmen heute haben unternehmen wie
chevron und exxonmobil milliarden und
abermilliarden an dollar in diesen
zentralasiatischen land investiert
politisch gesehen waren die beziehungen
zwischen israel und den usa im
allgemeinen immer recht gut aber jetzt
ist dieses empfindliche gleichgewicht
gestört tokarev hat sich moskau und
wladimir putin in die arme geworfen und
das ist etwas was einen echten
wendepunkt markieren könnte kasachstan
ist die zweitgrößte volkswirtschaft den
ehemaligen sowjetrepubliken nach
russland selbst und jetzt scheint der
einfluss des kremls zum ersten mal so
gut wie absolut zu sein
tja wie du siehst das jahr 2022 für den
russischen staatschef sehr gut begonnen
andererseits ist auch klar dass es neben
den großen gewinnern auch großes teil
ihrer gibt natürlich zusätzlich zu den
demonstranten selbst alles deutet darauf
hin dass es nicht beim großen ersten
verlierer um den ehemaligen staatschef
nasarbajew von einem großteil seines
gefolges handelt und der andere große
verlierer ist der westen insbesondere
die usa welche ihren einfluss in dem
land praktisch über nacht an den kreml
verloren haben an einen kreml der in
letzter zeit immer mehr siege zu
verbuchen hat also aufgepasst denn jetzt
das erste richtig spannend
die kosten eines imperiums
russland hat einen nischenmarkt gefunden
auf dem seine außenpolitik unschlagbar
ist einfluss gewinnen im tausch für die
unterstützung und den schutz
autokratischer führer dieses muster
konnten sie unter anderem in syrien
weißrussland wenn ihr zu reden und jetzt
in kasachstan erfolgreich anwenden und
geradezu zur perfektion führen
auf diese weise erreicht putin was vor
ein paar jahren noch fast unmöglich
schien er gewinnt nach und nach einen
großen teil des früheren einflusses der
sowjetunion zurück nur vischer weise
fängt er bei den nachfolgestaaten der
sowjetunion damit an aber es geht nicht
nur darum autokratische regierungen zu
unterstützen die stationierung von mehr
als 100.000 soldaten an der ukrainischen
grenze macht die absichten des kremls
deutlich mit moskau ist nicht so
spannend und ich glaube nicht dass es
sich dabei nur um wachsenden politisch
militärischen aktionismus handelt nein
dahinter steckt eine klare strategie die
putin seit jahren verfolgt in den
letzten zwei jahrzehnten hat wladimir
putin das militär modernisiert und neue
spezialeinheiten cyberkrieg teams und
söldner course geschaffen und eine armee
neuer geheimdienstmitarbeiter
herangezüchtet der mann ist ja vom fach
dies alles dient nur einem zweck den
alten einfluss moskaus aus der
glorreichen zeit zurück zu gewinnen
alles damit möglichen russland wieder
groß werden kann
aber warte kurz bevor du jetzt stolz die
sowjet hymne anstimmten dieses ganze
abenteuer kommt nicht umsonst es hat
einen sehr hohen preis wir sprechen hier
von wirtschaftlichen und strategischen
kosten das nicht dass kurz erklären
einerseits ist es sehr kostspielig
dieses ganze imperium aufrechtzuerhalten
all diese abenteuer erfordern immer
höhere ausgaben was bedeutet dass der
zivilgesellschaft ressourcen entzogen
werden um den einfluss des staates zu
vergrößern denn auch ein imperium ist
schließlich nichts anderes als ein
großes business man investiert und baut
eine große kostenstruktur auf damit
dieses imperium dann irgendwann wieder
geld einbringt in form von tribut
steuern exporterlösen und so weiter es
muss nun mal ein business case gegeben
sein sonst war der ganze spaß völlig
umsonst und das imperium bericht nach
kurzer zeit wieder zusammen um überhaupt
langfristig überleben zu können muss es
irgendwann mindestens so viel einbringen
wie es kostet die imperiale maschinerie
muss sich amortisieren können das wissen
die russen ja eigentlich sehr gut aus
ihrer sowjetischen erfahrung denn die
udssr setzte so viele ressourcen ein um
ihre militärischen kapazitäten
aufrechtzuerhalten dass ich am ende das
ganze land erschöpfte und den kalten
krieg verlor nach angaben des pentagons
hat die sowjetunion zum beispiel
zwischen
1974 und 82 sechsmal mehr ballistische
raketen 27 mal mehr panzer 7,6 mal mehr
gepanzerte fahrzeuge doppelt so viele
flugzeuge und 2,3 mal mehr boote
produziert als die amis im grunde was
sie von allem mehr produziert habe es
müsste ihr lichts moskaus einfluss war
nur von kurzer dauer und verschwand
schließlich als die sowjetische
wirtschaft zusammenbrach sie hatten noch
nicht einmal das gefühl den amerikanern
voraus zu sein die ja den
technologischen wettlauf anführten und
über eine unvergleichlich größere
kapazität verfügten in modernste
ausrüstung zu investieren die sowjets
hatten im gegensatz zu den amis nun mal
keinen business case für ihr imperiales
konzert
[Musik]
und heute sieht die geschichte nicht
viel anders aus die übermäßige präsenz
des russischen militärs und der
russischen außenpolitik führt dazu dass
moskau zwar seinen einfluss
zurückgewinnt die nationale wirtschaft
unter lebensstandard der russen sich
aber nicht verbessern russlands bip
gemessen in dollar erreichte 2013 seinen
höchststand die abhängigkeit von
natürlichen ressourcen wurde nicht
verringert wo die infrastruktur
krankenhäuser und schulen des landes
befinden sich in einem desolaten zustand
das erklärt warum laut umfragen wie zum
beispiel von lava das center
durchgeführt wurden mehr als 50 prozent
der jungen russin in ein anderes land
auswandern wollen mit anderen worten
russland hat genau das gegenteil von dem
umgesetzt was china die ganze zeit getan
hat peking hat in den letzten
jahrzehnten ganz eindeutig der
wirtschaft den vorrang gegeben aber das
ist noch nicht alles die russische
wirtschaft leidet ja unterpunkt dienst
möchtegern imperialismus denn dieser
zieht der internationale sanktionen nach
sich und jeder neue russischen übergriff
wird zu neuen sanktionen führen die das
land noch mehr herunter ziehen werden
und seine konkurrenzfähigkeit auf den
von china und den usa dominierten
weltmärkten ist ja quasi schon heute
nicht mehr vorhanden die frage ist also
was wichtiger ist der einfluss des
staates auf globaler ebene oder der
lebensstandard der russischen bürger und
ihre fähigkeit sich in der
weltwirtschaft des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts zu behaupten ich denke die
antwort darauf fällt eindeutig aus und
die russen selbst wissen dies auch
[Musik]
zur veranschaulichung laut einer studie
des lewada sein lassen wollten im jahr
2021 nur 32 prozent der russen ihr land
als eine von anderen sendern
respektierte und fürchtete macht sehen
bis 32 prozent mit anderen worten der
großen mehrheit geht es eher darum dass
sie selbst besser leben können
[Musik]
darüber hinaus könnten die jüngsten
russischen aktionen zu einem
unerwarteten ausgang führen der rückkehr
zu einem wettrüsten dass russland
einfach nicht gewinnen kann und nicht
gewinnen wird mit anderen worten wenn
sich die lage zuspitzt könnten die nato
die mitglieder insbesondere die
osteuropäischen länder beschließen ihre
grenzsicherung mit militärischen
investitionen in rekordhöhe aufzurüsten
diese art von wettrüsten hat seinerzeit
entscheidend zum zusammenbruch der
sowjetunion beigetragen und das szenario
könnte heute das gleiche sein
[Musik]
ja es mag und so vorkommen als würden
putin und russland heute ein mensch nach
dem anderen gewinnen und sie halten
sicherlich wichtige trümpfe in der hand
zum beispiel die energieabhängigkeit der
europäischen union gegenüber dem
russischen bären die eu bezieht sage und
schreibe 41 cent ihres erdgasbedarfs und
27 prozent ihres erdöl gas aus russland
seinen größten trumpf hat putin also gar
nicht selbst geschaffen diesen hat ihnen
die deutsche regierung in ihrer hastigen
und einseitigen energiewende zugespielt
die eu könnte in diesen trumpf daher
auch wieder entziehen wenn sie denn über
ihre eigene ideologische nasenspitze zu
blicken vermag aber trotzdem könnte sich
die geschichte wiederholen wenn der
jüngste vorstoß in kasachstan eines
deutlich macht dann das wärs mit dem
kraftprotz in russland der letzten drei
jahrzehnte zu tun haben auch wenn all
seine muskeln auf steroiden gebaut sind
und langfristig nichts mit einem
gesunden körper zu tun haben aber jetzt
bist du an der reihe denkst du dass das
interesse des staates über den
lebensstandard der bürger gestellt
werden sollte glaubst du dass russland
in der lage sein wird seinen
internationalen einfluss aufrecht zu
erhalten trotz einer hinkenden
wirtschaft die immer weiter hinter die
anderen großmächte zurückfällt wie
sollen die westlichen länder deiner
meinung nach putin umgehend immer sind
da auf deine meinung zu diesem thema
schon sehr gespannt ich hoffe also dass
diese video gefallen falls ja geht muss
mit einem like empfehle ist dein fronten
vergess ich das auto mit glöckchen um
keines unserer videos mehr zu verpassen
und unterstützen unsere arbeit bitte
auch mit einer kleinen spende über den
link in der beschreibung unter diesem
video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]